[Music]
you know it's so funny I get this
question all the time do you still
remember how it felt to drown it was a
crippling feeling I was suffocating
underwater now I've made it my job to
conquer my fear and to help to get these
kids some lessons and learn how to
respect the water
[Music]
my name is Colin Jones I was in the
Olympics in 2008 and 2012 and I love to
give swim lessons Colin Jones is a
four-time Olympic medallist swimmer for
Team USA right after getting the gold
medal in 2008 they put the drowning
rates in front of me and I learned the
70% of African Americans nearly 60% of
Latin Americans nearly 40% of Caucasians
don't honestly so it's a big problem all
over the US I think the reason that you
don't see as many African Americans in
swimming is because there's such a
stigma that black people don't swim and
this is something that needs to be
broken because we are losing children
you're losing adults and it's something
that can be changed by swim lessons
[Music]
swimming lessons are so important to
kids to me personally because I was well
almost one of those kids and part of
this statistic when Cullen was just five
years old he almost drowned on a water
side at an amusement park they had to
come out and grab me and resuscitate me
because I was underwater for about 30
seconds and I think what's important
about the story is that
I was fully supervised I mean it was
that easy and that quick for me to go
underwater that could have been my last
day on this earth and with that
near-death experience colin has made it
his platform to bring water safety
education to kids from all backgrounds
the way that I'm trying to change my
community is definitely with working
with to make a splash initiative I knew
this is my way of giving back to sports
that's giving me so much once you learn
how to swim it's like riding a bike you
never forget
so take the time learn how to surf the
beach is not a very safe space anyone
can relate to feeling uncomfortable on
the beach
men women queer otherwise and it's also
a very gendered space like the moment
you put your toes in the sand you know
it and you feel it and you know that you
have to kind of pick one side of the
spectrum either you're more on the
masculine side or you're more in the
feminine side what does that do for
everyone that doesn't exist on one clear
side or the other
[Music]
I am re Fitz and I run a fashion project
called tomboyish in so many ways aims to
tackle the way that we see beauty and
the way that we see masculinity and
femininity a couple years ago I really
started to balance my own masculinity
and femininity and I felt really good
and I felt like myself I wanted to help
other people get there - to me getting
dressed in the morning is kind of like
putting on my suit of armor as a queer
person as a woman as a person of color I
feel like there are so many things in
this world that wants to silence us
silenced me minimize me and minimize my
experience in this world what we choose
to wear signifies that we are here we
are present and we're not gonna be
silenced we're not going anywhere so the
project I'm working on is a really dope
super hot lookbook that features all
things swimwear for those who don't
exist on the hyper masculine side of the
hyper feminine side like myself because
I know what it feels like to step out on
the beach and not feel confident
we have to get creative we have to find
items that most of the time you wouldn't
really think are like swimwear or
beachwear pieces and we have to make
them ours swim vests also body suits and
then from there just accessorize it's a
beach it's meant to be fun it's meant to
be light it's suffered the stress and
the trauma that people experience when
they go to a beach it's just like it's
so unnecessary the more I can do to just
get that out of the way and and make the
beach fun again that means that my job
is on do you boo just rock it just make
sure you're like rocking it with like
you know some confidence and you got it
[Music]
everybody loves ice cream
even those who say they don't like ice
cream still love wisely we use ice cream
as a way to support our community my
name is Michael Mikey cold and I own
mikey likes ice cream
I did not always sell ice cream I was
born in the Lower East Side of New York
City's Village two blocks from the shop
while selling drugs at one point I ended
up getting caught and I'm going to jail
for six months a few years ago my mother
got sick I promised to her that I
wouldn't be locked up anymore I'd do the
wrong things ice cream was something
that just came into my life at a time
when I didn't really know what I was
kind of doing this is pop culture
inspired ice cream we attract and chill
truffle shuffle Ice Ice Baby employ mint
condition southern hospitality and we
have smooth operator I'm much of famous
people have I'm by here
futures are fed walking no as a fan
Hillary Clinton's affair
you have a lot of other fans out there I
still live two blocks from the store
part of our job is to still be heavily
in the community and so kids come in
here with a a on their report card to
give them a free scoop of ice cream
it's to show them that we are the same
as done so I'm just a little older but
I'm still the same child at heart and if
you can find something that you like and
you're passionate about go forth to just
go for it you know don't don't not go
for your dreams go for every last one
this you have Americans we love ice
cream each person eats about 24 quarts
of it per year and that's for one big
reason it tastes amazing but someone had
to teach Ben and Jerry's how to do it
turns out that guy he works at Penn
State this is dr. Bob
Robert hold on okay this is dr. Bob
Roberts
he teaches ice cream courses at Penn
State I do
I have two courses ice cream short
course and ice cream 101 side note these
are the type of books ice cream
professors read okay back to the story
part of the reason that ice cream is so
good in the u.s. is that we've been
teaching ice cream for 125 years and Bob
he's been teaching at Penn State for 25
of those and he's had some pretty famous
students companies like Unilever Nestle
Breyers Ben and Jerry's you name the
company they've sent people here that's
because the Penn State Creamery is on
the forefront of ice cream technology
ice cream is a formulated food there is
no naturally occurring ice cream you
have to put the ingredients together and
process it to make ice cream Bob in his
department they spend their time
figuring out how to make ice cream even
better when we look at studying ice
cream we study ice cream from cow to the
cone so we look at what happens on the
farm what happens with the milk
wait there's a farm we have a herd of
about 250 or so milking Holsteins and
yes they are on campus so yeah he knows
ice cream but he says that he's not an
ice cream purist I'm not sure what an
ice cream purist is but I wouldn't eat
frozen yogurt if I had the opportunity
to ice cream
yeah well that does make sense
considering he is the authority on ice
cream bob what's your favorite flavor
mmm don't see the leche yeah to be able
to be doing science while you're out
there insert for it
surfing down the face of the wave it's
just such a fleeting moment it's
incredible to actually be able to do it
smartphone is a surfboard fish you clip
it on the bottom of your board you go
out for your surf session it has
technology that measures ocean pH
salinity ocean temperature and very
detailed wave characteristics so there
will be an enormous amount of data
the reason these parameters are
important is because they are shifting
directly as a result of climate change
we have detailed information about the
deep ocean but very limited accurate
information about the near shore
satellites can't be really accurate with
data in that narrow zone and the other
way is ocean buoys and they are just not
deployed at the coast bingo
smart fin can fill that gap collecting
oceanic data is a very time-consuming
expensive process this is like you just
need to know how to surf the data moves
from your fin to your phone via
bluetooth and then from your phone it
goes up to our servers where
everything's processed I had to develop
sensors that don't affect the surfboard
nobody's gonna surf a fin that is not a
standard foil aside from that LED right
there is blinking that tells you that
there's like some sort of technology
there you wouldn't know the difference
so we've got a test tank set up now and
we're just trying to look at the
precision and accuracy of the instrument
itself things are looking pretty
promising
as a scientist it's pretty exciting to
be able to get data over these different
time and space scales I mean the fact
that you can go out and surf and
contribute to understanding what's
actually happening out there is
incredible I'm not a surfer I know
nothing about surfing I know I looked
like a surfer but um I'm not surfers are
very influential and care deeply about
the environment and want to be talking
about it
so smartphone is just a tool to do that
in a more concrete way
[Music]